salut tout le monde j'espère que vous
allez bien dans cette vidéo c'est
l'épisode final de ma série documentaire
sur Ragnar le Breton si vous avez pas vu
les précédents je vous recommande
d'aller les voir pour comprendre toute
l'histoire que j'ai essayé de raconter
et pour les autres j'espère que ce
dernier volet va vous plaire ou vous
touchez bon visionnage
allez encore au revoir mets ta guerre si
tu veux aller chez toi
on voit cadre 4 c'est moi qui va me
faire cadrer d'accord allez encore vas-y
encore allez chauffer encore
chez ta tête
la moitié encore encore encore encore
encore encore encore
tu n'es pas passé encore
de l'eau
cogite je suis confiant mais je cogite
quand même
il y a de la peur il y a du stress il y
a de la préhension mais il y a aussi
l'envie de faire quelque chose de bien
j'ai envie de me pousser dans mes
limites j'ai envie de j'ai envie de
saigner j'ai envie de toi
[Musique]
j'ai envie d'y aller quoi j'ai envie de
gagner quoi le but c'est de couper le
sang parce que tu as choisi
d'étranglement qui arrête le son non tu
dois pas faire ce que tu fais là tu dois
tirer ce coup-là
et en tirant dans mon dos et dans mon
dos je dois sentir un mur voilà très
très bon ok là on fait des schémas que
tu qui sont réguliers vu ce qu'on entend
ok la partie impro sur laquelle tu
choisiras pas les différentes phases de
sol on m'a donné des outils pour ça ça
te permettra d'improviser sur des
situations mais tu dois avoir beaucoup
de séquences sur lesquelles c'est assez
logique d'enchaîner
moi j'ai mon cerveau qui a la faculté de
se transformer dans des situations un
peu extrême tu vois je sais quand il
faut y aller faut y aller
par la peur je sais qu'à un moment donné
mon cerveau il arrive à passer en mode
allez c'est genre tu vas passer le pas
ça toujours été comme ça
[Musique]
bien mon matière
des trucs tout seul dans des parkings
avec des mecs autour et tout tu vois
quand j'étais plus jeune tu vois en fait
ce qu'il a fait toute sa vie là il peut
le reproduire dans une cage donc je
pense que ouais ça c'est parlant
il y a des règles
c'est structuré ça lui évitera de
prendre un coup de couteau derrière la
tête
sur le cardio
c'est comme si
j'ai plus de sous tu vois
mais là comme j'ai fait du blanc je vais
pas manger et tout j'ai ressentais que
le cœur il
un peu tu vois
ça fait deux heures et demi aujourd'hui
deux séances
ça va être important pour toi ouais j'ai
vu la France franchement c'était
très dur
pourquoi il se battait tout le temps
comme ça
bah je sais pas après je pense tu vois
qu'il y avait un mal-être un mal-être
quelque part un mal-être qui qui se
guérit pas forcément tu creuses un petit
peu c'est quelqu'un qui qui souffre
encore beaucoup tu vois quand il sortait
ça lui arrivait de sortir de temps en
temps
bah voilà il
lâche les chevaux et puis
malheureusement bah ça allait pas dans
le bon sens quoi
[Musique]
contexte familial tu es pas terrible à
cette époque là
[Musique]
où j'ai mes parents qui étaient qui ont
divorcé ou on avait un quotidien qui
était un peu violent aussi tu vois
les crises de colère dans les bagarres
dans les gestes dans les mots dans ce
qu'on a pu voir petit ça c'était quand
même dur
[Musique]
tu as grandi dans un foyer violent et on
a été confronté à la violence très tôt
tu as commencé à voir et je suis bien un
peu c'est violentes
ça a commencé à être un peu violent tu
vois j'étais un garçon aujourd'hui je
peux te dire qu'il y a vécu des choses
qu'il aurait pas dû vivre tu vois en
tant qu'en France on a perturbé tu vois
j'ai pas te mentir
[Musique]
avec ma maman j'ai toujours eu des
relations particulières
avec maman j'ai toujours eu des
relations très particulières j'ai eu
vécu de la violence physique petit ça
c'est sûr débranlés qui étaient beaucoup
trop excessive des excès de colère qui
étaient beaucoup trop excessifs de la
méchanceté qui était pas nécessaire
c'est comment dire c'est ça faisait
partie de ces démons tu vois c'est pas
elle tu vois ce que je veux dire
même aujourd'hui je pense que j'arrive
pas à faire le pas j'arrive pas à faire
le deuil de certaines sensations de
certaines émotions que j'ai pu ressentir
tu vois
c'est dur de dire ça je te jure je sais
pas si je pourrais lui dire tu vois
c'est trop dur
oui j'arrive
[Musique]
à grands-parents c'est souvent que bon
ils ont besoin de de se confier ailleurs
et puis c'est tout
écouter quoi
mais bon il disait pas toujours la
commande plus et puis moi j'ai obligé de
faire
à dire
les trucs que je pourrais jamais dire
parce que je sais que ça ferait du mal à
ma mère c'est le truc avec lesquels je
vais mourir et puis voilà c'est comme ça
tu peux pas
se mettre à nu comme ça je peux pas
c'est comme ça
j'en parlerai jamais
je n'ai jamais parlé des trucs que j'ai
pu ressentir ou que j'ai vu des gens ils
savent même pas ça que j'ai vu je l'ai
vu tu
vois jamais non parce que écorché vif
qui va me raconter une histoire pour te
faire un peu là
c'est vrai que quand il parle de
violence c'est sûr que c'est ma matin en
plus ça a été vraiment lui le premier
témoin de tout ça pas se mentir je pense
qu'il en a il en a beaucoup souffert tu
grandis avec et puis en fait le problème
c'est que les cicatrices d'enfance se
soignent malheureusement jamais à ma
Titi on va je vais mourir avec ouais
mais l'objectif c'est pas tu meurs avec
c'est que tu en parles avec nous et
peut-être que et cicatrices se refermont
quoi donc ouais après c'est des trucs
qui sont un peu c'est un peu c'est un
peu dur de voir ça tu vois quand je vois
mon frère comme ça c'est pas je sais pas
quand il parle de ce qu'il a eu
c'est trop dur pour toi ouais j'aime pas
ça tu vois
à côté de ça j'ai envie de rendre aussi
hommage à ma mère là dedans tu vois dans
le sens où elle a été une femme dans le
qui m'a transmis énormément de belles
choses toi que cela générosité que ce
soit le
son adaptation sociale que ce soit son
sens de l'humour son énergie tu vois je
la mettais dans une salle elle captivait
toute l'attention de tout le monde
[Musique]
parce qu'elle était belle parce qu'elle
était allée elle était sur d'elle elle
avait le sens de l'humour à l'oser plein
de choses tu vois ça veut dire elle
aurait pu tout avoir elle a eu de
l'argent elle a eu les gens qui sont
intéressés à elle par argent quand la
divorcé mon père c'est mieux qu'un
footballeur
et
elle avait tout tu vois les gens
à une grande maison à payer des vacances
à tout le monde appelle le loyer de ses
sœurs à payer des cours c'était la star
de la famille tu vois et à partir du
moment
où elle a plus grand chose
rideau puis personne n'a calcule
personne ne se préoccupe de savoir
comment elle va alors qu'elle est
fragile ma mère tu vois donc elle a des
grosses faiblesses donc du coup voilà la
sombrer dans plein de choses
et elle a une période très très très
compliquée ma mère
tu vois et
là aujourd'hui je la retrouve et je la
découvre enfin comme une maman tu vois
dans le sens où je vois qu'elle est elle
a besoin d'aide elle allait commencer un
petit peu elle fait des ménages en ce
moment tu vois dans sur en Bretagne et
tout et là aujourd'hui je la vois elle
est super je suis content de la
redécouvrir comme ça
parce que c'est une dame qui a des
qualités qui sont je te dis
extraordinaire extraordinaire
[Applaudissements]
je me disais que quand j'étais petit
quand je regardais ma mère je la voyais
comme je la voyais comme une reine
moi c'est ce que je me bats avec mon
fils c'est qui me voit toujours comme
son supérieur je l'ai grondé une fois
fort et j'ai pleuré après horrible parce
que je me sentais tu peux pas abuser de
ton autorité sur un bébé sur un enfant
tu vois c'est horrible ne serait-ce que
même physiquement j'ai jamais touché mon
fils je le toucherai jamais les galères
qu'il a eu les toutes ces difficultés
qu'il a eu dans son enfance son
adolescence et tout
c'est ce qui est fait qui ce qui est
aujourd'hui tu vois
en quelque sorte ces blessures c'est sa
force tu vois c'est ça qu'il a tu l'as
donné de la force de devenir qu'il est
aujourd'hui tu vois ça comme ça l'a pas
brisé
ça la forêt tu vois tu peux pas
[Musique]
reproduire les erreurs que tu as vu moi
je trouve que c'est absolument pas une
excuse
j'ai vécu ça donc je fais pareil non au
contraire tu as vécu ça donc tu dois
tout faire au pas que ça arrive tu vois
c'est comme des gens j'étais en enfant
battu donc je tabac j'ai tapé mon enfant
c'est juste un sac à merde
un enfant parce que tu as été battu tu
vois à partir du moment où j'ai eu mes
enfants moi il y a un truc qui
[Musique]
ça y est je suis devenu un autre homme
tu vois ça m'a comment j'ai expliqué ça
je sais pas franchement tu es quoi je
suis limite devenu un peu mou un peu mou
du cul depuis mes enfants c'est vrai tu
vois plus apaisé non mais même plus que
ça j'ai changé complètement
j'ai arrêté tout ce que je faisais avant
de mal je mens plus je vole plus je suis
plus d'escroquerie je suis en paix avec
moi-même et ça ça a pas de prix
à partir du moment où tu es en paix avec
toi-même
je m'assume tu vois je suis chez qui je
suis aujourd'hui voilà
j'ai deux enfants je suis très heureux
je m'assume tu vois ça veut dire ça a
pas de prix tu vois cherche plus à
plaire aux gens je les emmerde alors
je suis moi-même
ces enfants c'est pour lui là
tous les jours pour
ça mon papa
[Musique]
[Rires]
tu annules le combat parce que tu sais
très bien que je me suis préparé et que
toi tu as pris ça la légère tu dis c'est
un petit youtubeur je vais arriver je
vais le bananer Bam Bam quand tu as vu
je m'entraînais très sérieusement tous
les jours et que j'ai pris ça à cœur et
sérieusement je t'ai dit ah oui ah c'est
un peu relou je vais me faire tabasser
je vais perdre face à un mec qui est sur
Youtube soit un homme et viens te battre
[Musique]
c'est parti là on est 15 jours après
l'annulation de ton combat comment tu te
sens beaucoup mieux
relaxer moins de pression psychologique
moins de douleurs physiques et puis
retour et demi normal
la vie douce la vie de bohème la vie
d'artiste
voilà là mais la vie voilà que moi
j'affectionne plus quoi
faire du contenu créer des choses
rigoler
si j'ai envie de me coucher tard je me
couche tard si j'ai pas envie de dormir
je dors pas si j'ai envie de manger ça
je mange ça
pas de cadre pas me dire ça si je me
couche à 4h du matin [__] demain j'ai
parlé avec
avec un Camerounais que 53
j'avoue la moindre erreur peut-être
des trajets moi ce qui me rappelle les
trajets en voiture le matin
quand Lopez demain 11h c'est bon
ah bon tu es sûr
avec Robson
il m'avait dévissé la gueule la semaine
d'avant tu es sur la route et comme ça
tu te trompes
c'était un enfer là je te cache pas tout
je me suis arrêté je me sens mieux
je me sens mieux bon moi du coup je peux
te demander
déjà je me suis prouvé à moi-même que
j'étais capable d'y aller parce que moi
je sais dans ma intime conviction je
serai allé moi j'étais vraiment pris en
découdre je le sentais au fond de moi
j'étais j'avais vraiment envie d'y aller
quoi j'ai eu j'étais impatient d'y être
toi
maintenant j'ai envie de le faire pour
avoir la finalité de
pour finir la mission tu vois
après
trouver les créneaux trouver les machins
les timing parce que faut se mettre une
prépa machin bon mais je pense que
j'aurais quand même au bout de ce que
j'ai envie de faire au moins une fois
donc pas de rendez-vous pour
pas de rendez-vous pour le moment
peut-être novembre
tu vois
c'est mon passé le cap des 30 des 34
l'homme est le plus en forme
psychologiquement 30 millions
ça se passe avant 34
sinon je serais plus dans le coup quoi
parfait
[Musique]
voilà j'espère que cette série
documentaire vous a plu ou qu'elle vous
a un peu touché évidemment moi j'étais
déçu de pas pouvoir filmer le combat qui
a été annulé peut-être qu'il se fera
plus tard dans l'année on verra et je
serai au rendez-vous pour vous raconter
le fin mot de cette histoire en
attendant je suis content parce que dès
la semaine prochaine vendredi à 18h on
va diffuser notre série sur le gang des
Black Dragons qui combattaient les skins
dans les années 80 il y aura l'épisode 1
et toute la série sera disponible dans
la brut ou au fur et à mesure sur la
chaîne Youtube de brut donc voilà restez
connectés j'ai hâte que vous puissiez la
découvrir à très vite et encore merci
pour votre soutien